kim kardashian and pete davidson are
seemingly taking their love to the next
level and we're talking pda people we'll
just have to wait and see after almost a
month of romance rumors the two were
spotted in palm springs california last
week holding hands that's the 41 year
old kkw beauty founder dressed in a
white bodysuit gray sweatpants and
sneakers and that's the saturday night
live star in a navy calvin klein hat a
black t-shirt a pair of plaid skins
pajama pants yellow socks and sneakers
but most importantly that right there is
some hand-holding
yes
honestly the two look pretty darn happy
and we love to see it at the end of the
day life is about being happy
so just how serious is this whole kim
and pete thing a source recently told et
that the mom of four and the king of
staten island star are pretty into each
other quote kim and pete are dating and
having a great time together pete is a
romantic and goes out of his way to make
him feel special kim thinks pete is
hysterical and he's constantly making
her laugh but they also have been
connecting on a deeper level i love that
rumors of a love connection first
sparked back in october when the two
were photographed clutching hands on a
roller coaster at not scary farm
after kim's hosting gig on snl
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you going to kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
since then the two have been spotted on
a few dinner dates including one at
pete's favorite spot in his hometown
staten island and here they are last
week celebrating pete's 28th birthday
together wearing matching pjs from kim's
latest skims collection it's really lit
and and fun and crazy but when et
chatted with the comedian's snl co-star
alex moffatt he played coy when asked
about the rumored couple
i don't really stay up to date with what
my good friend uh pete's up to
i just hope he's vaccinated as long as
he's having fun and he's happy that's
all i care about he's a love
then there's machine gun kelly who's
good pals with pete they even
collaborated
the rocker was also tight-lipped about
keat you know kim and pete when e.t
caught up with him at the 2021 american
music awards sunday night gotta ask you
your boy pete davidson and kim
kardashian how happy are you for him
but we're happy yeah yeah yeah
of course pete who was previously
engaged to ariana grande and has been
linked to stars like phoebe denver and
kaia gerber is the first guy the reality
star has been romantically linked to
since filing for divorce from kanye west
in february
according to a separate source the two
are 100 dating and quote very into each
other quote they are pretty much
inseparable and very affectionate when
they're together
[Music]
you